her hair was piled atop her head often
ornamented with jewels or trinkets her
face was always made up and she wore the
finest gowns and jewelry at only 19
years old she was already a queen and in
the tumultuous times in which she lived
she soon became a symbol of all that was
wrong with French royalty so in the
video today let's explore the life of
Marie Antoinette the woman who was the
face of royal excess during the French
Revolution
though now inextricably links with
France Antoinette wasn't a native of the
country descended from the Habsburg
liner she was born into royalty in
Austria Marie Antoinette entered the
world in 1755 she was the daughter of
the Empress of Austria and the Holy
Roman Emperor like many born into
royalty she had a lengthly name maria
antonia Josefa johanna growing up she
was educated by private tutors her
education focused on morality and
religion this was typical at the time
for an aristocratic females education
though she had a private tutor that
worked with her Antoinette was no great
shakes at academics in fact she could
barely read and write her native German
much less the French that she also had
to study as one of her tutors described
she is rather lazy and extremely
frivolous she is hard to teach
Antoinette had grew up during the Seven
Years War she was only eight years old
when it ended but the outcome of the
conflict quite seriously affected her
future you see as the Empress of Austria
and Wynette's mother was the political
leader at the end of the Seven Years War
it was in her best interest to keep an
alliance between the French and the
Austrians
and in the 18th century the best way to
forge an alliance was through marriage
two years after the war ended when
Antoinette was the 10 years old her
mother pegged the 11 year old heir to
the French crown as her best bet for a
son-in-law the necessary arrangements
were made and at the age of only
fourteen Antoinette was married off into
foreign royalty to Louis Auguste Abobo
even Marie Antoinette's entry into
France's teenager was a spectacular
affair a caravan was made up of nearly
60 carriages accompanied by 117 footmen
and three hundred and seventy-six horses
the destination for this veritable
parade was a royal retreat in the forest
outside of Paris but they had to make a
stop as they approached the border with
France Antoinette had to be dressed to
look the part of French royalty
her hair was powdered her makeup was
done and she put on a dress that matched
the lavish expectations of the French
Court when they arrived
Antoinette showed herself to be just a
teenager she was impulsive and unable to
control her excitement about being in a
new place about to meet her soon-to-be
husband rushing out of the carriage she
dashed up to the King of France and when
she curtsied he was charmed but the
Kings grandson the future husband of
Antoinette did not share his betrothed
extroverted personality he did not - up
to her on her arrival
instead he averted his eyes gave her a
quick formal kiss on the cheek and then
stayed silence meanwhile Antoinette's
and the King chattered away merrily one
day after Antoinette met Louis the two
were married the May the 16th 1770
wedding ceremony was held in the chapel
of the famed Palace of Versailles
Antoinette's dress was white and silver
an opulent gown decked out in diamonds
but there was a major problem with the
gown it wasn't the right size for any
bride discovering on your wedding day
that your dress doesn't fit well it
would be a nightmare but imagine being
the future Queen with all eyes of the
court and the country upon you and she
did impress however at least not
publicly she was expected to walk down
the aisle and take the hands of Louie
Bob on in marriage so that's what she
did with a shift showing through the
back of her dress in between rows of
sewn diamonds the ceremony itself was a
long mess and the groom had on a dour
expression for the entire time then when
it came to seal the contract with the
signatures of the bride and groom
Antoinette dripped her ink on the
signature obscuring the name doing so
was considered bad luck for the marriage
and things well they didn't get any
better as the day went on it was
traditional in this era for newlyweds to
be followed to the bedchamber by a crowd
in the case of Antoinette and Louie the
crowd included Royal dignitaries and an
arch bishop the bishop gave a blessing
the crown display
and the couple disappeared behind drawn
curtains and they undressed but as it
would seem the entirety of Europe knew
the next day they didn't actually
consummate the marriage as was expected
of newlyweds and indeed for the next
seven years they didn't consummate the
marriage to this day there's never been
a clear answer to why it took so long
for the two to fulfill this marital
obligation historians have put forward
theories two of those popular theory so
that Louis had phimosis a condition the
men's sex was painful for him or simply
that the two teenagers were just young
and confused but it did seem that the
whole world knew about the lack of
intimacy between the young royals
including Antoinette's mother Antoinette
and her mother regularly correspondent
via letter than their discussions offer
a glimpse into Antoinette's early years
in the French Court and these reveals
that she was very homesick Madame my
very dear mother I have not received one
of your dear letters without having the
tears come to my eyes
we actually disliked the French custom
of royalty being attended to always I
presume my Rouge and wash my hands in
front of the whole world she complained
to her mother in a letter her mother
spent time in her letters admonishing
her daughter for her frivolous behaviour
at court as well as for not performing
her marital obligations in one letter
she told Antoinette that in order to be
a good wife she needed to lavish more
caresses on Louis part of the problem
might have been their different
schedules and lifestyles though married
they lived two very different lives
Antoinette was as outgoing and as social
as ever that her husband remained quiet
avoiding the frivolities of court life
that his wife Sarah enjoyed the
differences they grated on the marriage
Antoinette wrote to her friend my tastes
are not the same as the Kings who is
only interested in hunting and his
metalworking he would often go to bed
well before midnight while she was just
getting started with her party's late
into the night then she'd wake up late
morning after had already been up
tending to his duties or studies from an
early hour
eventually Antoinette's brother was sent
to France to talk to Louie it's not
clear what Antoinette's brother said to
Louie but after their chat the couple
was finally able to consummate their
marriage by the time their marriage was
consummated Louie's father had died and
the two had been king and queen for
three years and at this point she was
just 21 years old
as Queen Antoinette
tastes remained lavish much to her
mother's dismay in an almost portentous
letter her mother wrote you lead a
dissipated life I hope I shall not live
to see the disaster that is likely to
ensue her hair itself was a mark of her
opulence with wigs and ornamentation
piled feet at all our heads her hair was
so extravagantly done that she could
even honey - tiny vases of water in it
to keep the ornamental flowers fresh
Leonard outine hairdresser became a
cultural icon in his own right the women
of the court ins of high society in
Paris began emulating Antoinette's
hairstyles with mourning women even
going so far as to ornaments their
towers of hair with urns her jewelry was
also flashy to have her diamond
bracelets were worth as much as an
entire mansion in Paris just getting
dressed in the morning was literally a
production one of Antoinette's maids
would hold up a book of fabric samples
to help her decide what to wear then
she'd put on layers of undergarments
including a frame for under her skirt to
emphasize her hips a corset of course
then layers of fabric and then her dress
again her mother did predictably not
approve as you know I've always been of
the opinion that fashions should be
followed in moderation but should never
be taken to extremes a beautiful young
woman
a graceful Queen has no need of such
madness
on the contrary simplicity of dress is
more befitting and more worthy of a
queen I love my little Queen and watch
everything you do and feel I must not
hesitate to draw your attention to this
little frivolity the royal couple was
living well and showing it off but the
people of France weren't sharing in the
opulence and not all of the French
population was impressed with their new
Queens luxurious style in the late 1770s
the harvest in France it wasn't going
well grain was at a premium prices were
skyrocketing and farmers and peasants
they were hurting there were literally
riots in the street over bread it is
during these riots that Antoinette was
supposed to have said let them eat cake
but she never actually said this that
phrase was attributed to her much later
in 1843 Antoinette may have never
uttered that famously callous phrase but
she certainly wasn't sympathetic to the
plight of the peasants in fact even as
her subjects were suffering she
continued spending even more she gambled
and she spent money to construct her own
private retreat of versailles feet
building known as the tryin on already
existed antoinette though she needed to
make it her own she installed artificial
rivers a rotunda and a series of what
appeared to be in rustic cottages once
inside it became clear they were
anything but they were furnished in the
typically comfortable style of the
wealthy complete with pool tables silk
hangings and other ornate wall decor
fine china and luxury furniture brought
the cost of the retreat to an astounding
two million francs beyond the cost of
the Decker and the property the trial
also caused other problems for
Antoinette among her subjects people
wondered why a queen would need such a
retreat so they jump to conclusions and
began spreading rumors and gossip the
Queen she was hosting men they set
obscene gatherings had to be happening
at the Tryon why else would she need a
lavish getaway for just herself and her
friends one rumor it persisted and that
was of Antoinette's affair with the
Swedish diplomat axel de frst in 2016 a
team of researchers announced their
decoded a letter that showed Antoinette
and the first ins relationship went
beyond just discussing matters of state
among the decoded passages is this I
will ends this letter but not without
telling you my dear and gentle friends
that I love you madly and that there is
never a moment in which I do not adore
you
the two had first been introduced in
1774 and saw each other more and more as
first in attended more events at the
French Court he left Europe for a time
to fight in the American Revolution but
that didn't dim the feelings between him
and Antoinette another letter that
survived the centuries has Fersen
telling his sister that he could never
marry because his one true love was
already taken the Queen well she was
certainly giving the people of France a
great deal to talk about discussions of
Antoinette as a traitor's her husbands
and about her frivolity with money were
spread in pamphlets distributed
throughout France drawings and
Antoinette accompanied servic words
showing her in extravagant dresses this
drove great iya towards her and the rest
of the royal family
as leaking a green were acting as if
nothing was different about life the
people of France were getting angrier
and angrier in 1789 King Louie had sent
troops to Visayans Paris and French
citizens were starting to worry it might
be a move to dissolve the National
Assembly in response 900 Frenchmen
descended upon Paris and stormed the
Bastille prison they stole weapons and
ammunition but the event was much more
than a stockpiling of weapons it was a
symbol of the people being ready to take
on the powerful forces of the monarchy
the Bastille was a fortress but it was
also the prison where political enemies
were kept it was a symbol of the
monarchies power and by taking it over
the people showed just how weak the
monarchy could be the storming of the
Bastille on July the 14th 1789
is widely considered to be the start of
the French Revolution and things were
moving pretty fast by October the crowds
of revolutionaries had grown to
thousands ten thousand French commoners
gathered outside Versailles calling for
the king and queen to be dragged to
Paris
among them were thousands of women who
had marched miles from Paris and along
the way they were joined by men with
guns when they showed up outside the
royal residence Louis didn't know what
to do his first instinct was to escape
so he ordered his carriages be prepared
but they were no match for the angry
crowds the carriages were ruins and
Louis and his family remained trapped in
the palace they were much safer inside
though some of the crowds tried to get
it down to Annette's and they nearly
succeeded two guards were killed as the
crowd forced their way towards their
quarters and so net wasn't in the
bedroom though she had left earlier and
was safe in the dining rooms of Louis
quarters
soon after troops under the command of
Marquis de Lafayette arrived and were
able to restore order the feast was not
to last though the crowds were able to
capture the king and queen and force
them back to Paris in a procession led
by the heads of their dead bodyguards
which were hosted up on pikes throughout
the crisis Antoinette was meeting with
ambassadors and writing letters to other
European officials calling on them to
help out the French monarchy Louie
meanwhile seems at a loss for how to
help then in 1891 aided by the help of
her lover de Fersen and not Louis
Antoinette's put together a plan to get
the royal family out of France and away
from the danger of an ever angry at
public the plan was to escape to the
Netherlands
where they could plot a
counter-revolution Antoinette's proved
herself able to make decisions and plan
but when it came time for her to escape
her desire for luxury got in the way
again
a French General had told the Royals
that their journey would be much safer
if they made it in two small
inconspicuous carriages instead
Antoinette demanded that they use large
carriages that could be outfitted with a
full silver dinner service as well as a
wine chest also joining the royal family
in their luxurious carriage was deverson
the plan called for him to leave the
royal family a short way into the
journey then meet back up with them at
their destination he wanted to travel
the whole way as part of their group to
offer protection but Louis demanded he
follow the plan and separate from the
group shortly after the first ins
departure from the group they ran into
trouble a peasant recognized the king
and was able to muster up a crowd to
attack the carriage
they weren't dragged into a house and
held captive eventually they were
allowed to return to Paris but still
were held captive
the French assembly allowed Louis to
serve as king but he didn't really have
any power and Antoinette well she wasn't
much in favour of the assembly at all
she was actively working against them
writing to officials throughout Europe
about how terrible she thought the new
constitution was she was also pretty
clear in how she felt about the members
of the assembly themselves describing
them as a heap of black guards madmen
and beasts during this time Louis had
also declared war on Austria things they
were falling apart all around Antoinette
and they were about to get a whole lot
worse in 1792 the French royal family
was forced into the medieval temple
tower fortress as they were held
prisoner the millennium old monarchy of
France was dissolved and a new French
Republic took its place as all this was
going on outside the royal family tried
to live a somewhat normal life in prison
Louie and Marie tooted their children
played chess and played instruments but
they were also trying to bring the
monarchy back to power and it was this
effort that ultimately undid her and
Louie
the couple had hidden the letters they
received from foreign powers in a box
inside the prison when the
correspondence was discovered Louie was
dragged on trial he with ultimately
sentenced to death with the
revolutionary leader Rose Pierre
proclaiming Louie must die so that the
country may live Antoinette and their
children were able to spend a few final
hours with him before he met his fate at
the guillotine with 20,000 Frenchmen
looking
months later Antoinette herself would be
the one on the platform after Louie's
execution she was brought to a new
prison a prison with the dire nickname
of deaths antechamber here a sympathetic
military officer actually attempted to
help her escape when his efforts were
uncovered Antoinette was put on trial
right away in order to avoid any danger
of her escaping she was charged with
treason and theft and it was left up to
a male jury to decide her fate it only
took two days for them to decide that
she was guilty and she should be
sentenced to death the 37 year old queen
made one final trip through the streets
of Paris her hair Shawn in preparation
for execution she sat sterically in her
carriage on the ride to the guillotine
platform where she would ultimately meet
her face when she arrived at the
platform the priest told her to have
courage her response courage I have
shown it for years
thank you I shall lose it at the moments
when my sufferings are to end from the
moment she was born Marie Antoinette was
destined to play a role on the world
stage a mother set her up for a powerful
marriage a marriage that thrust her into
the midst of the French Revolution and
made her the ultimate representation of
the excesses of royalty
she was only alive for 37 years but in
that time she certainly left her mark on
the world so I really hope you enjoyed
the video if you did please hit that
thumbs up button below and do not forget
to subscribe also we've got a new
feature if you would like to vote on who
we do here at Baia graphics you can
visit our companion site it's called bio
graphics org and click on the bio vote
in the bar at the top and then you'll be
able to suggest people and also vote on
existing suggestions so go check that
out and as always thank you for watching